[Music]
and there was one time that was pretty
scary over there nobody got hurt I hit
somebody's house but it doesn't hurt a
little bit I was very worried because I
didn't know where's my brother
running upstairs telling my father and
my mother about that and then I told my
father that there's a fire this girl is
telling me about a moment when someone
threw a Molotov cocktail which she's
calling hot paint over that wall into
her apartment complex but the casual
nature with which this little girl is
telling me this story is a clue that
this isn't your typical apartment
complex I'm in East Jerusalem in a
Palestinian neighborhood but I'm in a
compound called male has 18 where a
number of Jewish families live
surrounded by fortified walls and
private security this girl's school bus
has bulletproof glass I got into this
compound to ask them why they're living
here one component of this building
these buildings these six buildings is
that they are a physical structure in
eastern Jerusalem with a flag on top and
says the Jews are here Israel's here she
is one of about 2,600 hard-line
religious Jews who buy up homes from
Palestinian families in Palestinian
neighborhoods often clandestinely and
with huge sums of money from
international donors I visited some of
these families to better understand the
motivations at play here
and to see what life is like at the
ideological epicenter of this conflict
[Music]
in 1948 the newly declared State of
Israel was fighting a war with its Arab
neighbors that war ended with a
ceasefire line called the Green Line if
you zoom in to the Green Line you'll see
that it goes right through Jerusalem
with Israel controlling the West and
Jordan controlling the East and
Jerusalem's Old City which is this tiny
piece of land where Jews Christians and
Muslims all have holy sites was right on
the Green Line but it was on the east
side controlled by Jordan and during
that time Jews were not permitted to
visit the Western Wall which is the
holiest site in Judaism then in 1967
Israel seized control of the entire West
Bank including East Jerusalem Israel
then pulled a highly controversial move
they declared that the eastern part of
Jerusalem as well as 27 Palestinian
villages surrounding it were now a part
of Israel they erased the Green Line
that separated the city and drew a new
municipal border announcing that it was
now unified Jerusalem the capital of
Israel on paper this map does look
unified but in reality the city remained
completely divided the Palestinians in
the East didn't want to be a part of
this new country that they had just been
annexed into so in order to cement their
claim and establish a Jewish presence in
Eastern Jerusalem Israel built 12 huge
neighbourhood blocks adjacent to
Palestinian neighborhoods in East
Jerusalem while simultaneously creating
policies that limited Palestinian urban
development in the east the world saw
this is illegal and refused to recognize
Israel's new definition of Jerusalem but
that didn't stop Israel from building
these neighborhoods but there's a
difference between the 200,000 Israelis
that are living in these 12 big
neighborhood blocks and the Israelis who
buy up individual properties in
Palestinian neighborhoods the big
neighborhood's serve as a way to
establish a large Jewish presence in
East Jerusalem it's part of a political
strategy to claim large sections of land
preventing any future division of the
city but the Israelis that are buying
individual Palestinian homes have a
mission that
is different their objective is based
more on the biblical significance of
tiny pieces of land throughout the city
the settlers of East Jerusalem have a
thermal map not everything glows with
the same intensity they settle areas
that resonate with biblical history and
have a proximity to the Temple Mount or
at the very least are within the visual
Basin of the Temple Mount that is their
homeland there are two right-wing
organizations that are dedicated to this
aggressive settlement project they have
targeted a handful of spots in the city
that they want to occupy but that are in
Palestinian neighborhoods these
organizations raise large amounts of
money from international donors and they
use this money to buy properties from
Palestinians for a price that is well
above market value the settlers are
persevered and they will spend years
chipping away to try and get one
property once they've secured a property
they will move a Jewish family in
sometimes under the cover of night and
escorted by soldiers the families are
then protected by 24-hour private
security that is provided by the Israeli
government costing about 25 million
dollars per year to the Israeli
taxpayers for these 2,600 Israelis
living in Palestinian neighborhoods
needless to say Palestinian neighbors
are not thrilled about these secret
militarized move-ins into their
neighborhoods
I spent a Friday evening with several of
these people to better understand their
motives we walked up from one compound
up the Mount of Olives to another
compound for Sabbath prayers this one
was purchased from a Palestinian man who
was in debt from a gambling problem and
they both have women and they bought
half of a good place I watched these
settlers pray as they look down over the
city and as I talked to them I began to
realize that in order to understand why
they do this you have to understand the
internal logic that they adhere to the
whole project of the State of Israel is
a Jewish project the State of Israel is
the biggest Jewish organization you if
you want to vote in the Jewish country
there's an easy way become a Jew we have
a way in and then you can you can have a
affectless country if you so wish but if
you're another minority then god bless
you you have a huge region Allah loves
you
these hardliners believe that Israel
exists primarily for Jews and thus
they're entitled to rights and benefits
that others are not we like democracy
but it's not a god it's a it's it's all
it is is an operating system if it needs
to change if it needs an update you know
if you need to download the latest
version it needs to change for your
particular environment to them going out
and buying Palestinian homes isn't a
politically dubious land grab in fact
it's a noble spiritual mission one that
has been prophesied about for thousands
of years so when I'm living in this
place give me a purpose it gives me a
reason I'm and even if I'm not doing
something ideal as it could this means
that at that moment that I'm living in
faith video advocate gives my life every
second to me and thanks to effective
lobbying by these groups the Messianic
paradigm has seeped into government
policy as well aiding the settlers on
their mission to sink roots into the
eastern part of the city an example of
this is a law that says only Jews can
buy property in the Jewish quarter of
the old city
but that anyone can buy property in the
other quarters the settler organizations
have targeted the muslim quarter for
their purchases due to its proximity to
the Temple Mount and they now have
dozens of Holdings there the government
has also granted these two organizations
jurisdiction over many of the public
spaces in the city that have been deemed
archaeological sites or Nash
parks some of these sites are situated
in Palestinian neighborhoods that are
the top of the list for the Jewish home
purchases places like so on in the City
of David these right-wing organizations
are using their jurisdiction to shape
the public realm of Palestinian
neighborhoods to reflect their agenda of
a Jewish Jerusalem the result is a
government supported militarized
ideological gentrification of Jerusalem
one house at a time as we zoom out you
can see that between the national parks
and the individual properties these
organizations have amassed a strong
influence of public and private in and
around the old city where their holiest
religious sites are meanwhile the
Palestinians who live in East Jerusalem
are in this weird legal limbo where they
live in the municipal borders of the
annex city of Jerusalem but they don't
have Israeli citizenship they can't vote
in national elections this leads to
severe neglect from public investment
the reason for that is politicians never
allocate resources funds time
entitlements to people who don't vote or
can't vote
almost 90% of the sewage pipes roads and
sidewalks in Jerusalem are found in the
West and you can see that the
proportions of public resources are
heavily skewed towards West Jerusalem
even though a third of the population
lives in the East last week the
municipality said we will renovate
the schools in East Jerusalem that are
in desperate need their dilapidated and
overcrowded but you have to adopt the
Israeli curriculum something that the
Palestinians have refused to do since
1967 so your kids can study in a decent
physical environment provided that you
peddle your national identity in
exchange for that that's the kind of
Faustian deal that the city Palestinian
residents abuse Persian are not going to
accept it's hard to imagine when or how
this situation will ever be resolved
Palestinians in East Jerusalem don't
want Israeli citizenship they were
annexed against their will into a
country that doesn't recognize their
full rights and as Jewish neighborhoods
grown East Jerusalem Israel's grasp over
the city becomes tighter and tighter
[Music]